foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
welcome to the show welcome to the show
we're back all right let's get straight
to it let's get straight to the
nitty-gritty we're back after last week
you know we we the parlay trended in in
a direction that we did not want it to
go but that is okay that's why we are
back and I'm blaming it on Ryan I'm
that's that's that's just how I feel for
the real ones that are in here that
remember remember that we closed the
show with Michael bowling saying it's
gonna hit because Riot had nothing to do
with it now whether I did or did not
drop Jason Tatum's points it doesn't
matter because it was six legs and seven
of them didn't hit so it kind of matters
I don't know it seems like that should
matter
yeah I'm not gonna lie Ryan your leg
was not the vibe no it was not it Robert
Williams also wasn't the vibe so I was
telling y'all I didn't want that I I
like oh this guy this guy calls me the I
Told You So guy and then he's like oh I
didn't want it I'm just saying I was
trying to give you guys the heads up but
I mean speaking of the Celtics they're
back
and we said in our private slack Channel
that we're gonna fade the Celtics from
now on and sure enough boom here they go
NBA Finals rematch so now what
now what well we take the Celtics minus
six and a half right
absolutely not see this is what we're
just what we're talking about
myself dude the national TV Celtics the
the TNT Celtics not the the other
Celtics the TNT Celtics uh kill it no
they're fantastic no I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna lie dose plus six and a
half is very enticing tonight very
enticing
well I saw stat that the Warriors are
5-1 against the spread versus the uh
Celtics in their last six so that would
support you what say you Ryan
uh well I mean you're including the
finals correct
yeah when it matters this game doesn't
matter the Celtics will probably win it
what's up guys let's start the show I'm
so sorry give me the three bucks give me
the three bucks I need the three bucks
because we got to do this right we gotta
do this right welcome to the show
everybody welcome to the show my name is
Greg Ivory next to me is a guy I like
they call MB you might know him as
Michael Boland but he is the bleacher
report app whisper and next to him
do it do it go back to the other screen
like let's just
now producer Ryan hey we got beef we we
got we got a little beef this week bro
we always got beef but I don't know what
oh that yeah it's a little it's a little
it's a little extra this week because
you know my teams are playing your teams
so you know the beef is real this week
with me and Ryan like I need uh if
they're even cow emojis put the beef put
beef in the comments because the beef is
real yeah there's some steak emojis I'm
sure all right we got some rat emojis
though so I mean
you know or that that's that's never
going to change on a week to week basis
I see my guy bath Ave boy 99 he's asking
if we're using the FanDuel no sweat
tonight and the answer is 100 yes you
already know what time it is you guys
see the Emoji on the screen or
oh
Greg
I see that I see that they got the rats
on here where's the beef put a beef up
there because it's beef between me and
Ryan it's beef hey Ryan um last week we
already said you ruined the parlay but
you're trying to say that you did it so
uh it's time to cook up another one it's
time to cook up another one drop your
Best Bets for tonight's TNT games in the
chat we said
TNT games only in the chat that's
Warriors Celtics net Suns Ryan what are
the people in the comments talking about
uh outside of dropping steak emojis and
rad emojis uh we've got badhave boy 99
uh saying Jordan pool over 19 and a half
points uh we've got
am I seeing I think I'm seeing Scotty
Barnes well guess what he's not playing
on TNT tonight
um so let's see yeah it's tough uh rsj
says Celtics money line a lock and we
might get into that later but Greg's not
gonna let me do it so it's a battle that
I have to win
uh just being honest uh Buddha 600 Tatum
30. I don't know if I like that Luke
Swope Tatum two plus threes I you can
convince me more on that and then leak
Porter Andrew Wiggins over 14 and a half
points so I say we go either Tatum two
plus threes or Wiggins over 14 and a
half points I don't know how you feel
Greg and bowling but like Jordan you're
not even gonna read out my guy Darian
giving me some props for the Pat will
play today wow where is that hold on
all right
I'm I'm scrolling up you are looking
down that's the problem
what hey right yeah I don't know if this
is true is Jordan pool's assist numbers
at two and a half it might be I mean
there it's usually low because you know
Jordan pulley doesn't like to pass it's
all about that stop it we put this we
put this in I think I think pool assist
was in one of our first week yeah yeah
easily is he not up there no why wow why
wow they really that means they don't
want us about it I am intrigued by
Jordan Poole though I mean he's playing
really well obviously Steph coming back
opens up a little bit for him when
they're on the floor together I kind of
think we may should maybe should start
with the 20 points for Jordan pool
tonight
I saw that in the chat too two different
people said that my my as a warrior fan
as a warrior fan
Jordan pool he's just inconsistent he's
inconsistent
he's good he's very good he's very very
good uh uh Prospect but he just
isn't there yet
now facing this Boston team who's who
who's a defensive team they're going to
slow it down and
I don't want to talk us out of it and be
but I'm just kind of skeptical
yeah we don't have to start there I
think that's one of the knocks on him
right like he can go for 40 one night
and then he might go two for ten from
three and give you 12. so it's not a bad
handicap I think that you know you're in
a spot that you watch this a little more
than I do so
I'm interested if we can finally assist
um I do think he's gonna make a big
impact in this game though I I think
that sis if it's there and that's love
but if it's not then we definitely
understand why it's not there because
it's easy money uh all right I see green
green over six and a half rebounds you
took the words right out of my mouth MB
I just saw that I just saw that Draymond
Green over six and a half and I have I
have uh some data up saying that he's
right that and seven of his last ten so
it's money right it's plus money
foreign
I think we let it ride too it's plus
money he's going to be looking for clay
he's going to be looking for Steph a lot
a lot
ah we'll start we'll start there wait
are we talking assists or rebounds
because I thought we were talking
rebounds
I think the play in the chat that I saw
was over 6.5 rebounds but yeah I saw
rebounds I mean assist too oh well we'll
do rebounds no no no no no no no no no
no no no we'll do a rebounds six and a
half rebounds like I can get behind this
I can get there I like I like the
rebounds I like the reasons I'm just
saying
no this is not gonna be the Draymond
Green parlay
all right
assist I want this to be clipped onto
that show what are we doing what are we
saying
just isn't that what you like to do
throw things in our faces yeah but it's
Gotta we haven't hit a parlay in such a
long time because of you yeah well
that's debatable
I don't know about all that I don't know
just to be honest yeah all right I
walked into that one that's that's on me
we're gonna move on here
um
I like Marcus Smart a lot I don't know
why I'm not seeing any of that in the
chat Marcus Smart always plays well
against the Warriors so uh this is me
prompting uh Marcus Smart plays because
we're gonna need some of that I see uh
the most recent I see is D Harris 22
saying Dre not getting that over tonight
not with Boston's defense oh he's
talking about the assist over he's
talking about the assist over I think
that that's it that's a different story
I think the boards has nothing to do
with their defense obviously I think
there's going to be a really close game
you know NBA Finals Vibes there's going
to be opportunities for assists or for
rebounds yeah I agree uh the vaporist
said Draymond is on his uh do not bet
list
Fair he's probably on a lot of people's
do not bet list but he's been recently
yeah and like we can't really hate that
because we we said last week that the
entire Boston Celtics team is on our do
not bed list but yeah here we are um
all right guys and you might like this
one uh Ryan bet babe a boy 99 how do we
not take Tatum points over at home he
dominates the Warriors no one can guard
him on their team I'll be honest
uh so here's the here's the thing with
Tatum and I I tend to agree I think that
he is really really good against this
team I'm scared of his points over is
what 30 31 Maybe
I might be down to lock in his threes if
it's over one and a half but it's
probably over two and a half it's it's
three and a half here oh Jesus no we're
not doing that somebody said Marcus
somebody said Marcus one three and five
assists I would be very okay with Marcus
over one and a half threes oh I trust
you Ryan I think he puts him up he does
put him up he does yeah it's a it's a
it's it's a good play in my opinion
because what's one ah one's gonna be
like minus 25
000. is it not minus one thousand but
you get the point that's the same thing
yeah yeah yeah I I like I I like this
like yeah the thing I know about Marcus
Smart too is like these are the games as
long as he doesn't lose his mind and get
a tech like he gets up for these games
for sure so I imagine he I could see him
hitting this over in like the second
quarter
I agree I know Sports 27 wants us to
look into Jordan pool threes now you
said last time Greg we did we did this I
think it was one of the only legs that
didn't hit and you didn't like it so
first of all kudos to you I'm giving you
your chops shout at me for humility
shout at me uh but also
I like
I like it we're going to talk on it
let's talk on it but I was gonna say
let's look for some layups let's look
for some layups now like we got two
straight solid beds let's look for a
layup to mix in here a couple layups and
then we could probably put one more
solid bit but let's get strategic on how
we do this one
um
do we like Jordan pool like teasing it
down to two maybe what does that do for
us minus 270 that's kind of terrible
I just don't know fellas I remember
Andrew Wiggins on there then
for two oh wow that's interesting what
about for one
no that's not gonna do anything
I didn't hate that President either
216 I guess it's the 216. for this no
sweat promo we have to get to at least
plus 400. otherwise it's not no sweat so
right that gets us to where we need to
be with two legs left
okay you so you like you like Wiggins
one made three
well you were you were saying yeah no I
like it I'm just making sure you like
like you guys are within the chats with
it yeah I I don't hate it at all I mean
for Wiggins he's made at least one three
and four out of his last five and he
just those are the only games he's
played since he's been back so he shot
six eight eight four and seven so the
volume is there I mean I I have a lot of
history betting on Wiggins threes he he
cashed me out in the finals last year so
I'm with it if you guys are
oh spicy sponge dropped in here smart
has been trashed Lately from three one
of four three of twelve two of eight
well spicy sponge uh
two of those numbers you gave us are
over one and a half covering hey yo hey
yo I'm about to I'm about to I'm about
to mix this up y'all hey take out take
out Andrew Wiggins and put Dante
divincenzo love me some Dante yes you
see that Ryan yeah
he said Dante divincenzo has slept on
y'all
now
is the fact that he was playing a lot
when people were hurt now it's like
short minutes but he he's always come
through for me so I'm definitely with it
especially one three
yeah I'm I'm all in uh Mike Steve Ritter
jumping in here uh Ryan quote shout out
me should we tease this down Roberto I
mean
oh
hey guys guys
Dante divincenzo I I heard you MB I
heard you but the thing about Dante Diva
Channel I've been watching this Warriors
team and look at the numbers look up his
recent numbers but like
when Steph was out
Dante was in the starting lineup with
pool and they were gelling they went on
that winning streak at home uh but since
he went back to the to the bench row
Dante has thrived in that bench row
Jordan pool hasn't so much thrived in
the bench row I think Jordan Poole wants
to start I think he's a young player he
should be starting but you know he has
two Hall of Famers in front of him
Stephen Clay so he's not starting but
what I'm saying is Dante divincenzo
thrives in that bench role especially on
this Warriors team so with that being
said what is his points numbers what is
his points numbers uh also James Wiseman
33 jumped in here and said Dante gets
boards uh if this is the real James
Wiseman
uh for the purposes of myself will be
reported it's actually somebody somebody
is actually the Greg parlay no it's fine
I mean I like all three of these plays
and truly just seeing uh points bro put
bro bro what
over Ryan why are we even thinking about
it okay here's one thing I want to note
and I agree with you Greg we don't have
to do a parlay for both games if we want
to just do a game a four leg parlay for
this game we could run it
like we can add another leg we can add
another just like we could add one leg
from the late game if we want one layout
yeah like whatever Kyrie's total points
is just under
what's uh how many minutes is Dante
playing now let me check you guys you
guys look it up and take a look it up
look it up but eight
come on man stop playing
okay
if the Warriors game my bad MB my bad
and B but if the Warriors like lose they
get blown out he's gonna be out there in
mop up minutes getting buckets
hey by the way
we got the chat in here saying I'm a
snitch for coming after James Wiseman
I'm trying to win guys you know if James
Wiseman gets suspended for a year that
benefits the Celtics I mean what are we
doing
I'll be a snitch dude I'll make a fake
Stuff Curry count put it in here I'll
get him suspended too what are we doing
you're just validating the fact that
you're a rat to the chat that's fine
listen at a certain point I'm gonna have
to own it right I can't fight it if
everyone's gonna jump in here drop an
emoji if the graphics people are gonna
put it on screen
okay
[Music]
that's wild
Greg I went and checked he played 27
minutes 26 minutes 25 minutes and 18
minutes he covered the number in his
last three I don't know what happened
against the Suns on January 10th but I
think that was like a major blowout
potentially so yeah he only played it it
seems like a good it seems like a good
number to me it's got us at plus 500
already I mean like
because at five to one that's pretty
good value for a four leg parlay hey the
other thing MB the other thing he did
not make a three-pointer in his last
game he did not make it three films last
game and he still had 11.
but the last time well we need him to
make a three-pointer in his parlay oh
right I just want to say that I just
want to say this the last time he didn't
make a three-pointer in the game the
next game he said five I'm just saying
I'm just saying that's true I'm just
saying it looks like just the last time
I didn't make a three before January
16th was December 27th that's a long
damn time yeah
Sun's Game was a blowout he knows
obviously because he was there so uh
right he was on the back should info
yeah that's good info shout out to you
James Weissman James Wiseman how much
are you putting on this parlay just so
we can just so we could document this
let's now you're taking it too far this
is not a RICO case yeah all right so
look guys
says one more leg in the late game one
more leg in the late game I agree but I
say we are ready at plus 500 let's go
get a minus 1 000 layup
and like like
Kyrie over 20 points
let's pause we don't need him one minus
1000 when we can get Kyrie under 20 and
29 and a half points
no I don't like that the Suns have been
so terrible lately he might get 30 and
three quarters and get out of there
look at this stuff
Ryan that might hit I might hit listen
man to be honest but like oh my God
you're with him Greg this is crazy no we
went from losing the last couple weeks
to now trying to win a A plus a thousand
no no no no no no no no I'm not with him
wait this is what we could do we could
probably because it's plus one thousand
we could probably tease Draymond and
Marcus Smart down and then all we got to
do is sweat Dante no no why no no no no
no no no why all we need is to get the
plus 400. that could be here
we need a minus thousand we need a layup
to finish this parlay off
I like it I don't want to use this this
is too much man
I don't know spicy sponge says Ryan come
on bro
exactly spicy sponge is a hater all
right spicy sponge just jumps in here
and hates
I think he's hating because he wants to
win like we don't need to do all this to
win we can what if here let's play along
with because I got
I have my hands on the keyboard This is
now I'm the captain now see but he gets
so territorial Greg I got my he says I
got my hands on the keyboard we gotta
fix it we get it somebody somehow we
have to fix this
I should be able to hover and take over
[Laughter]
uh it doesn't even get to close 400 so
that's a problem that's I will admit
hand up that is an issue
okay so I see you taking the chat
I see it taking the chat no no don't
even don't even nope take off the Dante
three no it doesn't make sense
not you bro I'm talking to the chat if
we're going to bet his points we might
have bro he shoots threes go look at his
numbers I agree he shoots threes four he
shot he put up four threes he put up six
threes he put up 12 threes he put up
three put up 11. like he shoots threes
hold up hold up hold up in that same
vein because you just dropped the stat
before where it's like he you know he
sucked one night and he didn't make any
threes and the next night he was you
know Reggie Miller should we just take
the over one and a half threes it's plus
money Greg
that that was going to be my take if
we're going to take both the threes and
the points we might as well just take
the plus money for two threes and take
the points out and there we go we got
this five leg parlay and it's plus 506
and we're gonna win money and that's
there's no that still has the points in
though
huh what's the five legs what points I I
see four
yeah yeah the fifth leg would be uh what
we all agreed on already was Kyrie under
29 and a half okay I thought that was
gonna boost it up to like a thousand no
not but that's if we did it the other
way I think we're cool just leave the
Kyrie stuff in and then we're good and
we'll get out of here
what are we doing
what a parlay how it's gonna hit
so confused a few what do we oh the Dre
band Draymond four rebounds thing
oh so he put down rebounds okay I get it
we got to take that under out of there
and talk about something else yeah
yeah
why
I don't like it why do you think that
he's gonna go under against the Suns uh
two reasons uh one I have a personal
Vendetta with Kyrie Irving Steve this is
I don't want to hear that I don't want
to hear it
to take it out bro I don't want to hear
no personal vendettas because that's not
gonna make us no money what you need to
do
hey and let's start over he mentioned I
said it's still trying to go to bed and
give us one layup it's to her I trust me
I'm not going bed until very late
tonight so you don't gotta worry about
that uh all right what if we do
let's go back to rebounds this is
literally Ryan you said we haven't won a
parlay in so long this is why we sit
here we have winners we have them we
have them drawn up and then you come and
do your propaganda you you do the Orion
dear Ryan Switcheroo you're gonna call
it a [ __ ] weren't you you're gonna call
it a shtek yeah yeah yeah you're right I
heard that yeah this is no [ __ ] this is
me
uh all right so I mean if we do dream on
thing not a not a fan of the Kyrie Kyrie
underplay so
uh D Harris saying we don't care about
your personal feelings I don't care
about your personal feelings D Harris
how about that how did that feel that
probably didn't feel good did it I don't
care about you either
how about that I'm over here rolling
that bagel and lock saying rat having
the mouse
doesn't make sense
how about the joke
oh snap
oh my God oh my God
that's a good one
oh my God boy so take the mouse away
from the wreck
oh my gosh all right all right listen we
set ourselves up in a scenario here look
where we it's plus 390. so if we go and
we and we you know take a minus 1000.
no no no no no no wait I'm sorry MB
Draymond over six and a half rebounds
not six plus look at the odds when you
change it don't you like odds
but all I'm saying is is that all we
need to do is get to plus 400 and this
is no sweat so if we go and we take you
know Kyrie one plus made three in the
next game and then boom we're at plus
400 and then we can just wrap it up and
go home
yeah I don't know though all right
yeah
okay all right okay I had a good we got
a good we got a good suggestion for the
for the uh lock in the next game Rocky
Mountain 52 20 5280 says eight and over
rebounds there it is right it's a very
good one no but like again let's go to
Let's I'm sorry go ahead Ryan go no no
no no no I'll just do what everyone
wants it's fine
go to Aiden's rebound and let's
let's go dude let's just take it down
all the way some we're already at plus
491. yeah I mean it's gonna get six
boards bro what's the six boards do they
can't even they won't even let me do
four
yep do that plus 524. all right 24.
there it is there it is Ryan there it is
I mean like but to be fair you know what
what can we do here hold on like if if
we go if we go and we say uh well let's
you know protect ourselves from a bad
beat with Draymond and we go to Six and
we're at plus 410 and we're still guess
what we're no sweating we're no sweating
we didn't go to the gym today we're not
sweating we're pretty drunk that's not
enough or okay so now we're in the back
now we're now we're playing the ping
pong because we know what do we have it
at six boards we have it yes and we want
six and a half he's gonna get eight
boards or ayton if we want to put ayton
up to get the value up a little
is that what we want to do
yeah just check on it we might as well
bro why are we
I just don't understand the fact that
we're gonna lay like a whole dollar over
0.5 with drema
I well we don't have friends I'm just
saying what if we changed ayton who's a
vacuum down there from six to eight do
we still get close to the 500 yeah
that's pretty good
that's not bad it still doesn't make
sense to me like over 0.5
when do we ever get burned by the hook
on this show
win right remind me you probably
personally might get burned by the hook
but on this show on our parlay when do
we ever get burned by the hook
I I think there was a time where we bet
Tatum 30 plus points and he finished
with 29. I actually think that happened
very recently by the way but that isn't
the hook
technically he is correct
oh boy I mean well let's let's see what
they mean let's see what the chat says
do I want to go with the hook I mean
either way I think we're in a good spot
to be very spicy let Ryan Cook uh well
spicy sponges you know they he goes back
and forth with me uh how about this I I
will concede we will go I because only
because what's his who in here Mike ice
86 said hell no ain't no my no bet list
he's not good okay well even if you
think that DeAndre ayton stinks on ice
and he doesn't want to be in Phoenix
because the sun stink and they can't get
along and they're a bad team yeah all of
those things are true he will still get
six rebounds that is correct we all
agree with that right even on his worst
night he is getting six rebounds he'll
get six three months by accident 100
okay so then let's go back to what we
had originally we'll go six boards for
eight and six and a half for Draymond
Green I don't know I mean like this is
still plus 400 but I I could see it
no we're gonna we're gonna ride with the
six and a half all right we I think the
idea that
we had in the beginning we should stick
to
all right Greg all right man look we're
out look at this
we want to review it but see yeah we can
review it but I I like what's the
problem I don't get it I really don't I
do these shows with you I do these shows
with you oh everything is suspended now
what's happening oh what we're about to
get cooked
is about to come back and it could be
minus somebody with the game somebody's
not playing or something all right well
and this is like a member this is
suspended no it hasn't all right we need
a squad ride for tonight so I know
Logan's in here listening
I wanna I wanna evaluate some plays
while we wait for this to come back
how's that okay
all right so Logan says the Bulls game
just ended so this is suspended if you
have a lock drop it in the chat and
we're gonna pick outside of our parlay
a squad ride to use tonight
so let us know what you think honestly a
lot of talk about Kyrie
listen the sun stink they're really bad
without Devin Booker if we really like
it
could be a good play on a single bet to
just rock with Kyrie's points but I want
to know what the chats got to say we're
back we need a squad ride and we haven't
started great okay
all right back to back no no wait wait
we're a family we're at we're suspended
again no good all good uh we're we're a
family
and I tell you that Kyrie Irving is on
my enemies list and now we're Squad
riding him no I was set and I'm not
listen I don't give a I don't give two
scoots about Curry either what I'm
saying is some people like it and if we
want to use it for a squad ride I'm not
gonna hate on that because it's a single
bet and it's not a part of the parlay
okay A and B you know what that's you
know what that sounds like to be honest
somebody man a man of the people
of the people
somebody's Mike ice 86 said James
Wiseman made it hot so they suspended it
no it's closed yeah oh my God and they
found out that James Watson's in here so
blame James Wiseman which I'm sure you
were doing anyway Greg
so uh actually like I actually like
James version yeah he's all right he'll
be a good trade piece for you guys but
uh all right this is gonna be the parlay
for tonight Draymond Green over six and
a half rebounds whoa excuse me that's
gavage that is good vibes that's what
you guys want to know that that never
happened before yeah if you sneeze on
the shows give us has that happened
before you ever never ever
I got a new dog and I'm a little
allergic to it but but I'm getting
immune like getting immune to it just
gotta you just gotta how that works is
that how that works bro it's it's real
honestly Ryan I was like you I was like
against it but I swear it's real
again against against what so we're
getting we're getting a lot of takes
are you the squad I was allergic to dogs
and I never was around dogs I was like
anti-dog because I was allergic to him
but no oh I'm not anti-dog I mean I
shouldn't have gone that far because I'm
definitely not anti-dog but I was just
like skeptical being around dogs I have
a dog I'm not anti-dog
Brian what are we talking about MB go
ahead and go away I'm saying you guys
are you guys took this off the rail
first of all Kelly being in the chat
says bless you Greg so that's good vibes
shout out Kelly B um we have Mike ice
likes the Kyrie straight bet for for the
squad ride Simmons over rebounds and
assists for Squad ride
I don't know man let's let's uh let's
let's grade some of these because we
need to pick something sure
uh
I see one case slack did you read that
Ben Simmons over seven and a half
assists I think that's a good one I kind
of like that one too 1K slack is a good
vibe uh username as well the two games
Simmons has had a lot of assists
recently I think there was one game he
had 10 assists by halftime I do think
that they're gonna blow the Suns out of
the water and you know he doesn't shoot
so
that seems like a good bet to me yeah
bagel and locks jumped in here and said
points rebounds for Simmons you
basically when you're saying that you
just mean rebounds because he's not
gonna score uh but the two games that
Kevin Durant hasn't played this year
that that Ben Simmons has he got nine he
got nine assists and 13 assists and it's
at seven and a half tonight I would take
the seven and a half
who's my guy 1K slack shout out you yeah
easy
yeah hey guys what up do we lock in the
parlay uh do you want me to read it one
more time or do you want me to yeah
three more times like you usually do
wait do we even know do we even know
that it's alive yeah it's alive I'm
staring at it went up by the way to plus
528 so uh Ryan let's lock it in for the
people one more time brother Draymond
Green over six and a half rebounds
Marcus Smart one plus three Dante
divincenzo over one and a half threes
made Dante divincenzo over eight and a
half points DeAndre in six plus rebounds
there it is I like it I like it I think
it wins I think it went but then again
every week yeah we think not say we
trust we take this every week so Dante
we trust me so we grade it
the good thing is yeah I was going to
say the good thing is we'll know by
two hours from now if we're dead or not
but I think we're gonna hit
The Vibes we'll be fine uh Uncle Mal
jumping in here saying also it's cheese
pizza not plain pizza Ryan uh you're
wrong
you're wrong no he's right I don't know
what the hell you're talking about I
don't want to do this again man wants to
do it is that I thought we're all men of
the people but it's all of a sudden it's
I disagree with Ryan you can't be a man
if you call Pizza plain pizza you can't
be a man of anything right what am I
forcing it's the it was the first
comment you're forcing it bro you can't
force being a man of the people who have
to choose yeah you're trying to force it
I'll let the the people know also if
you're gonna call me a rat if you're
gonna call me a rat New York rats love
themselves in pizza so wouldn't I know
wouldn't I know
all right uh on the side all of a sudden
I'm using the slander as
no because rats love cheese and that's
what it is cheese pizza so damn right
they like pizza they don't like plain
pizza you think of rats gonna eat a a
piece of dough with with sauce on it I'm
getting mad like I said like I said you
call it Cod cheese pizza it's already
it's already cheap it's already cheese
is already
you gotta stop my man mb's from Chicago
bro they know about pizza out there
thank you they know about hot dogs they
don't know about pizza
you're you're being you're being out of
line and I'm not gonna listen to it
still coming up soon so I'm gonna be
judged
debatable very debatable if you're going
to saboro if you're going to Sbarro if
you're going to 7-Eleven
what I'm that type of guy or do you
think that I'm that type of guy I don't
know this is the pizza capital of the
world if you don't like pizza in New
York I don't know where the hell you're
going dude if we're gonna all sit down
and we're all gonna have Chicago deep
dish together
yeah be ready
be ready Brown out tonight does that
does that make us worried about anything
in the parlay no it makes me not feel
more confident probably yeah it's
probably a good thing yeah you feel more
confident so that's big but but I'm
gonna be honest I went to New York
tasted pizza I've been in New York
couple times and tasted a pizza multiple
times not impressed not impressed well
and to be fair there's bet the pizza is
better in New Jersey anyway
flimsy like this it's just like paper
not impressive your pizza is lasagna
bowling we don't and we're gonna have to
get off the show
hey hey Ryan read the parlay one more
time let's take this uh let's take this
off offline let's take this debate
offline
all right Draymond Green over six and a
half rebounds Marcus Smart One Plus made
three Dante divincenzo over one and a
half made threes Dante's ivincenzo over
eight and a half points DeAndre eight
and six plus rebounds five legs plus
five twenty eight
hey Ryan they try to see you to
Sacramento
don't do that don't do that man
that's like sending me to Tulsa Oklahoma
what's there you know what I mean
I went I went to uh he set up with the
Pizza Hut nah I went to the I went to
the original you feel me the one yeah
yeah
I see it I love I love I love Jeff man
he's a great dude he's saying deep dish
pizza is pot pie deep dish pizza was
made to have all tourists come to
Chicago and eat at all the places that
we don't want to go eat so we go get our
thin crust pizza and yes if you have
hating takes on that I will not defend
it but hey Ryan Chicago's thin crust
pizza is absolutely unequivocally better
than that garbage in New York
whammy double doggy guarantee you
Sacramento got better Pizza than New
York Sacramento Sacramento
Sacramento got better Pizza than New
York
double do they even know what's
happening
do they even know what pizza is in
Sacramento
yes are they aware it's California it's
California bro it's the best state still
ever to ever live in that listen I have
no beef of California I have beef at
Sacramento I like there is nothing in
Sacramento there is nothing in
Sacramento you have to realize
Sacramento is the capital of one of the
best states in the United States okay
Hey listen Tallahassee is the capital
the best team best the best okay yes no
I can't say [ __ ] on the show on the
show but that's [ __ ]
Sacramento
Sacramento
is the jersey of California Oakland is
Oakland is like a jersey listen dude
shout out to Jay blow 57 he said we all
need this part of the latest hit so we
can afford some pizza this is the second
day this week where all we've talked
about is pizza and now we won't have to
eat pizza again yeah now we want it
that's true Hey listen dude Tallahassee
is the capital of Florida nobody goes to
Tallahassee
he doesn't know geography
geography he gets it dude he gets it
it's just that you drive through
Sacramento that's it you don't stop you
don't stop if you stop if you stop
you're low on gas
Sacramento is the heart of Northern
California
it's the heart of it San Francisco is
the heart all right here's what we're
gonna do and the chat's included we're
all gonna put the money on this parlay
and we're all gonna give flights to
Sacramento
I can't argue I can't argue with that
Ryan San Francisco is a great place to
be yeah I know but as as our fearless
leader Sam Richmond would say I know
ball you know what I mean I know
California
yeah all right San Francisco San
Francisco's clam chowder is like doing
dances around Boston's clam chowder but
we don't have to go there we don't have
to go there we don't have to go there
but I one thing I do in Sacramento's
Pizza is 10 times better than New York's
pizza and we could do we could we like
we can we can taste taste test Ryan we
can send you out to Sacramento and taste
test dude you first sending me to
Sacramento is like that's almost sounds
like punishment but you know if we need
to do it then we'll do it but
that's what it is geez well we got a
good parlay I know that we got the pizza
take back in here now it's time to win
now it's just time it's time to win it's
time to win Let's Get on Up out of here
man Ryan y'all see the party I'm not
gonna have them read it again right
there take a screenshot of It Go bet it
go ride with us because we're gonna win
we're gonna win I'm feeling the Good
Vibes today let's get on the fighter
here because it's some money to be made
my name is Greg Ivory next to me is the
man I like to call MB you might know him
as Michael Bolton but he is The Whisper
Of The Bleacher Report app and next to
him is the man that I'm beefing with but
the man that I got mad love for producer
Ryan producer Ryan uh he thinks he's a
man of the people but we're still
working on that I'm shocked dude I'm
shocked they didn't toss a rat over my
face I was really mentally prepared for
that you just want them to do it now
they did it enough times they did enough
times
it was being a dead horse he's like
really wanting you guys to put a red
just put a rat over his face he wants
you guys to do it producer Ryan my name
is Greg Michael Bola we about to hear
peace
laughs
[Music]
[Music]